tan
Yeah Yeah Yeah, the
first full-scale fighting game nationwide online battle was realized, and
one year from the operation of Tekken 7, which made players all over the country hot.
7 Let's take a preview.
Overwhelming evolution is trayed. In addition to the creepy graphics, a
redesigned costume design and a
battle full of presence and exhilaration are realized.
From the character image field
Ultra Street Fighter-
Uchihameshimaou Bocchichenzo
Tokyo-colored characters in the Street Fighter series The operability remains the same
.
A color that seems to be a street fighter Super combo gauge
Inheriting the skill
get Insect-proof my counsel that fights in the world
me The
battle changes
everything Stacey's temporary character Chika-
Silent Assassin
Iida who advanced to a pure white wedding dress  In
this work, the page's first Coober is early.
The wisdom of a system that enhances strategicity has passed. Coat agent
A new request specializing in offensive
characters.
In addition, hr t Performance game that causes more damage to the opponent as the physical strength is less
.  In addition to nationwide online
battles, even with the store child theme Chen
Go, if the stores keep in touch with each other
, free hey exchange battles will be held
and online battles with friends will be possible.
Present-designated matching will be realized.
You can enjoy a certain battle that transcends the distance. More thank you. The fun of the
battle spreads. You
can basically take over the customized items and ranks that you got with Tekken 7.
An interlocking site that improves the convenience of the let and is easier to use a new a new
me A
lot of powerful customized items are added, which is
full of originality  Characters make the battle different colors Yeah yeah yeah
q It's a
new graphic that heats up the battle with a new graphic
that has been expanded and evaluated.
A unique item full of dog-likeness love
An element that puts the player's cheeks
Continued Tweet ane A
new beginning behind the heavy and heavy house
Silly
ana
see
Yeah Yeah Yeah
Ingredients
Schedule
yeah yeah yeah
ben